salut je suis un ami de mme warren dans
ce que vous croyez être une vidéo sur ce
que vous appelez youtube vous allez en
réalité passé un test interactif sur le
voyage dans le temps pensez vous être
capable en seulement quelques questions
d'arriver au bout de ce test je vous le
disais il ya quelques secondes chez un
ami de mme warren qui a recruté cinq
personnes originaire d'un petit village
village qui s'est fait attaquer
violemment il ya quelques jours par le
ténébreux nous avons deux grandes
raisons de penser que l'une de ces cinq
personnes serait la réincarnation du
dragon connaissez pas mais c'est un
puissant chaleur très anciens une
prophétie raconte qu'il viendra un jour
pour sauver le monde ou pour le détruire
c'est à la fois notre meilleure alliée
dans notre combat contre le ténébreux
mais potentiellement c'est peut-être
notre pire ennemi nous craignons que le
but du ténébreux soin de détruire la
trame là où tout existe et là où tout
est lié c'est pourquoi j'ai demandé au
puissant china l'heure de lancer ce
sortilège afin que vous puissiez nous
aider nos deux univers sont parallèles
et le savoir de ait aidé une
organisation de chaleur m'a permis de
voir que notre monde à nous exister chez
vous sur la forme d'un roman une sorte
de saga de plus de 90 millions
d'exemplaires à travers votre monde est
maintenant sous la forme d'une
incroyable série sur une plateforme qui
s'appellerait prime vidéo puisque tout
vient d'un livre cela veut dire que
l'auteur de notre g existe chez vous si
vous arrivez à remonter le temps vous
pourrez alors lui faire écrire
différemment la prophétie afin de nous
assurer la victoire c'est pour cela
qu'avec ce puissant sort nous avons pu
créer ce message visible dans votre
monde qui va me servir à recruter celle
ou celui qui nous aidera pour effectuer
cette tâche dans votre univers dépourvu
de magie vous devrez tourné à linverse
de la roue du temps
c'est pourquoi j'ai créé ce test
interactif qui me dira si vous êtes
capable de remporter le défi mais
attention à tout moment je serai capable
de savoir le nombre de points que vous
avez est ce que vous m'avez répondu à la
dernière question ce n'est pas qu'une
simple vidéo si vous voulez en savoir
plus sur nous et sur the will of time
voici quelques images je vous grave
également un lien dans la description
qui vous permettra de voir toute notre
histoire sur prime vidéo que je remercie
d'ailleurs puisque c'est grâce à eux que
ces tests existent sachez qu'en ce
moment il ya 30 jours offerts pour les
nouveaux abonnés pour continuer cette
vidéo interactive vous n'aurez qu'à
cliquer sur la vignette qui vous
intéressent directement sur l'écran je
vais la faire apparaître mais si jamais
le ténébreux m'en empêchent ou les fait
disparaître alors vous pourrez
simplement cliquer sur les liens que je
graverai également dans la description
bonne chance et bienvenue dans la
cinquième vidéo interactive de cette
chaîne youtube